so now it's my turn and I expected that
something like this might happen it had
to had to happen I've been successful in
fighting against the left's agenda
especially the trans agenda and
especially recently those who support
the sexual mutilation of children know
full well that I am a threat to them
because we're winning and they're losing
and they know that too and they can't
engage with our with our arguments they
can't uh oppose us on the battlefield of
ideas so instead they look for another
way and now they're convinced they found
their kill shot against Me by using the
same method they always use which is
digging up ancient history doing the
internet equivalent of rummaging through
garbage cans to find things that were
done and said years ago which can be
used to defame and they hope silence me
today so yes my my PR team over at Media
Matters apparently wasn't satisfied to
promote just my current show and all the
work they do there so they decided to go
back 15 years to my time as a rock radio
host on an obscure station in uh
Delaware which is also an obscure State
and they spent it would seem many
tedious hours listening to segments and
bits from my time as a shock jock in my
early 20s it could not have been easy to
sit through I I commend their
persistence at least
and now they've compiled their findings
into an expose that promises to reveal
my quote sordid pest
honestly I I never thought of myself as
having assorted past I figured my life
was far too boring and sort of uh banal
and normal for that
but it turns out that I'm a more
interesting person than I had previously
thought
so as for the vultures and Media Matters
and the leftists who've picked up this
hit piece and run with it they are not
very interesting they are doing what
they always do they're as pathetic and
desperate as I've always known them to
be
the left they're not interested in
investigating children's hospitals that
literally castrate and butcher children
in fact such investigations I've been
told are an act of terrorism
but they will take the time to scour the
internet for evidence that I made
offensive remarks when I was 23 years
old
that in their minds is far more relevant
to the public it's a matter of uh of
Greater National urgency they think
so with that in mind
let's talk now if this is what they want
to talk about for a few moments about
the deep dark secrets of my past these
skeletons that have been hiding in my
closet waiting to be discovered by
Intrepid reporters and Media Matters I
will tell you the whole ghastly story
even the parts that Media Matters didn't
include
I'll tell you the whole story
so when I was 20 years old I moved into
a one-bedroom apartment in a small town
in Delaware and started working at a
rock station with a staggering audience
that easily reached into the
hundreds I think
those are my humble beginnings or or
maybe the dark and Sinister origins of
the world's most notorious terrorists
depending on who you listen to
so I worked at the station until I was
25 for a couple of years during that
period I hosted a Morning Show
where we often did flout the rules of
political correctness as was the custom
on morning radio at the time in their
headpiece Media Matters presents
evidence
that I used racially insensitive humor
that I told inappropriate jokes
that I engaged in lots of offensive
activities
all of that
of course is true they also accuse me of
physically abusing our radio interns
by tasing one of them as a joke
that's also true and I submit still
funny
In fairness I got tased too in fact I
invented a game back in those days
called taser trivia where as the name
suggests you are asked trivia questions
and if you get it wrong you get taste
Media Matters didn't post that video but
but they should have because it's quite
shocking literally and figuratively so
I'll post it for you now here it is
category will be science and nature okay
any question
what astrological chart takes its name
from a Greek word meaning circle of
little animals oh no no hold on all
right
astrological chart that takes its name
from what
Circle
this again
this sucks guys getting the taser out
circle of little animals circles little
animals
um
um uh it uh
just answer it uh the answer is uh uh
uh the uh the chart of um
of uh
the chart of magnesia
oh God
now if I should be canceled for anything
uh it for it should be for for being
such a such a pansy in that video like
that was embarrassing actually
get it together I mean it does hurt to
get to get tased and for some reason we
decided to add the blindfolds into it as
well to just make it more because you
never know when the tase is coming
our biggest mistake was that we used
Trivial Pursuit questions we use like
old school Trivial Pursuit as the
questions should taste of trivia I don't
think anyone got the answer right so we
just got taste 50 times
anyway that's the sort of content that
you missed out on if you didn't live in
Southern Delaware in the early 2000s but
there's more Media Matters reveals that
I once challenged the intern to lick the
inside of a dumpster
which again is true but the part they
leave out is that afterwards we called a
doctor on the air to find out what sort
of diseases he might have picked up from
the stunt
and from what I recall the answer was uh
many
also again as Media Matters exposes like
any other hacky Morning Show at the time
we did prank calls and some of the prank
calls were offensive by current
standards sometimes on a call I would
imitate a black man on one occasion I
attempted to portray a man with split
personalities one of whom was black and
the other white it was very high concept
sort of work and it worked better on
paper than it did in execution I could
tell you but not all of our prank calls
were racially charged only most of them
were
we did one where I called a hotel
pretending to be
pretending to be a wizard who had left
his magical sword in his room
it was I think without question the
nerdiest prank call anyone has ever made
and it deserves to be recognized
as such in the Guinness Book of World
Records I submit
but Media Matters didn't include that
video in their expose maybe they can
find room for it in the follow-up that
I'm sure is coming
uh yet it wasn't all fun and games Media
Matters reports that I made politically
inflammatory statements including at a
tea party rally where I got into an
argument
with a guy in the audience while I was
on the stage and it ended with me
calling him and quote old fart
that's the kind of devastating insult I
could throw around before I became one
myself
but my political extremism wasn't
confined to yelling at people at uh tea
party rallies
one thing Media Matters doesn't mention
perhaps doesn't know
but now they will is that I ran for
mayor of my town at that time and and I
lost by a vote of if I remember
correctly 450 to 26.
the campaign ultimately floundered
because I never uh campaigned and also I
had no platform of any kind and I mainly
just entered the race because I thought
it would be funny and it was and also I
really wanted to try my hand at making a
corny campaign ad where I say absolutely
nothing of substance and that at the end
of the day was really the only reason I
ran was just so that I could
do this here it is
[Applause]
off we need to remove the alternator and
slip past the water pump let me get that
half inch socket
thanks
all right let's give it a shot here
oh hey how's it going
friend cranky got himself stranded again
car broken down you know something
just strikes me I think georgetown's a
little broken down too don't you
but don't worry sometimes you just need
a friend to come by and help you out of
a jam and that's all I'm going to do as
mayor of Georgetown but to fix a car
just like to fix a broken City you need
a few things
first of all the right tools a wrench
well works perfect for a car but not for
a city to fix a city what you need is
some integrity
a little bit of honesty how about some
character
and then there was that LSD we talked
about earlier loyalty strength and
devotion
I truly can't believe I only got 26
votes but it doesn't end there other
leftists have joined the hunt digging up
their own evidence and this is when the
pilot pylon starts happening right one
of them starts it and says look at all
these terrible things and then everyone
else says I'm gonna find more terrible
things and they did they found more
terrible thing things one now viral
video that's making the rounds online
shows me and my co-host burning a book
over a charcoal grill
and then we then dance around the flames
and make whooping noises like Indians
that's all real you see that video it's
100 real we really did that but the back
story is that we had the author of that
book whose name I forget on the show and
he annoyed us for reasons that I also
forget so we said we were gonna burn his
book in reprisal and we did
and again it was funny
though in hindsight probably not the
best thing to do in the middle of a
political campaign
but the left is not satisfied so merely
accuse me of racism terrorism political
extremism workplace violence
they're also absurdly claiming that I
advocated child Brides
and for that bit of defamation they are
using another segment from over a decade
ago where we discussed the issue of teen
pregnancy
and I pointed out that in the past teen
pregnancy wasn't considered a problem
because people got married younger I was
attempting to highlight in an admittedly
awkward and rambling way in my early 20s
riffing off the top of my head during a
rock Morning Show to an audience of
almost no one at the time the fact that
unwed pregnancy is a core problem that
plagues our society and it's still a
problem even when the unwed pregnant
person is an adult so no matter the age
I argued at the time pregnancy has
become a crisis when they happen outside
of marriage without a stable family
structure in place to care for the child
this was again not an issue in earlier
times because people got married young
and stayed married
it's not the way our society is today
though of course
at its core it's a rather
uncontroversial historical observation
but the left has latched on to this
point from years ago and tried to use it
to flip the groomer label around on me
accusing me of quote promoting teen
pregnancy and even child rape as some of
the
libelist statements would have it this
is a defamatory lie they know it's a lie
and it shows how desperate they are
they've chosen the most toxic smears
available because smears are all they
have
now in summary my enemies have thrown
every last thing they can at me the
whole kitchen sink and a few of the
appliances to go along with it I'm not
the first person to get this treatment
obviously I certainly won't be the last
their objective is nothing less than the
wholesale destruction of my life in my
career that's what they're going for
that's the price they expect me to pay
for opposing them effectively they hope
to force me to submit and apologize at
which point of course as it goes they'll
shoo me away with my tail between my
legs out of public view out of the Arena
off Into Obscurity
This Is My Punishment you know the life
sentence they expect me to serve for
trying to stop them from abusing and
butchering children
and it's not just me thereafter you know
they want to send a message to everybody
else they want to send a message to you
that if you stand up against them this
is what happens
they want to make me into another head
on a spike one of many
they put out on the edge of town a
warning to anyone else who might think
about
disobeying their rules
so here's my official answer
for the record
um
kiss my ass
I do not apologize
in fact by All rights you sick freaks
should be the ones apologizing to me
for lying and defaming me and doing it
all because I'm trying to prevent you
from sexually mutilating children
you damned monsters
you child abusing Psychopaths
I wouldn't apologize to you soulless
parasites if I had a gun to my head
instead I'd rather just tell you all to
piss off
I apologize for nothing I concede
nothing
I Will Never Surrender even a single
inch of ground to a pitchfork mob of
degenerate morons
you know the secret they never say out
loud is that nobody is truly canceled
unless they consent to it and they
willingly play their assigned roles
well I do not consent
and I'm not going to play the game
I'm not going anywhere
I am more motivated than ever to oppose
you
and to fight against everything you
stand for
because I hate everything you stand for
and I hate it more with each passing day
so you can try to humiliate me you could
try to ruin my reputation you can accuse
me of all of the most heinous crimes
that you can invent in your tiny
feverish little brains
but I am not going anywhere
staying in a fight never leaving
I promise you that
also for the record I will always
maintain that tasers are a wonderful
source of Comedy
that's not going to change either
that'll do it for us today as we move
over to the members block of the show
hope to talk to you uh then if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]